The moral presuppositions of a culture
are instantiated in its stories.
They're not instantiated then
it's explicit philosophy.
There might be a layer of
explicit philosophy and of
course there is in the West
in a layer of explicit law.
But underneath that there are stories and
there isn't anything under the stories
except maybe haven,
you know,
and that's so implicit.
It doesn't even actually count.
It's not a cognitive operation.
And so this is the story.
These are the stories that
are underneath our culture.
And so there better be something to them.
That's what we hope.
And but more importantly
maybe we shouldn't toss them
away without knowing what
they mean.
Because if we tossed them away then we're
throwing everything that we depend on
a way as far as I can tell.
And we will,
we will pay for it.
We'll pay for it individually
because we'll be weak.
You know?
Cause if you're not firm
in your convictions,
then someone else who's
from their convictions can,
you're their puppet like instantly.
And then you're also the
puppet of your own doubts,
right?
Because unless you have convictions,
you're going to generate doubts
like mad cause everyone does.
And then the doubts when,
and you'll be paralyzed
because there'll be,
you know,
50% of you moving forward
and 50% of you frozen,
stiff and that'll be enough
just to lodge you in place.
And so,
okay,
so there's a psychologist [inaudible]
of the idea of leadership,
which is very important.
And then it's associated
with the idea of character,
logical development.
And it's associated with
the idea of struggle,
not happiness.
And it's also associated
with this Abrahamic idea,
which I really liked.
And which was something that's been very
useful to me as a consequence of doing
these lectures.
Because remember at the beginning
of the Abrahamic stories,
Abraham's like a stay at home guy,
right?
He's like the guy who's 40
years old living in his,
in his,
in his mother's basement
and God says like,
get,
get the hell out of there.
You know,
get out in the world where you belong.
Go do something difficult because
what you're doing isn't acceptable.
And you know,
the first thing he does is go somewhere,
there's a terrible famine,
and then he goes somewhere.
There's a tyranny.
So,
you know,
it's,
it's pretty funny.
He follows God's call and it's not
like sweetness and light and paradise
immediately.
It's nothing like that.
It's,
it's instantaneous combat,
you know,
of the most difficult kind.